how crazy how [ __ ] hard is Amanda
Nunez hit its nuts she does it like she
I don't want to say she hits like a dude
cuz that's kind of weird yeah it's a I
remember being surprised I remember like
having this open guard on the ground and
kind of like come here you know like I
dare you and then she hit I was like oh
you know you could see the look on
people's face when she hits him like we
saw it with Ronda like right away
there's a part in that fight because I
watched our fight after and like you uh
she hit me and it like did something I
think it's right when it had to be when
I hurt my head cuz it like dropped my
arm and it dropped my neck and I just
remember like seeing like the little
Twiggy Tweety birds and I was pumped
because I was like that's where the
cartoons get it from because somebody
explain that [ __ ] that's exactly where
they got is like and my arm like I
couldn't get my arm back up and I
remember listening to you and you're
like cubs not intelligently defending
herself I'm like listen Joe yeah you
know and then she screwed up because she
grabbed my knee and my knee was the one
that was like the catalyst to all my
problems over the last couple years and
it was just like don't [ __ ] touch
that and after that it was just like I
got angry when she grabbed me yes it was
the wrong knee but I knew what she was
trying to do yeah and then on top of
that is like it's just I don't know the
rest of it was just like punishing her
she's kind of like sassy before the
fight anyways like in awkward ways like
not even like cool hypee ways like just
staring at me really weird in a room
where it was just like me and tim
kennedy sitting there eating like
watermelon and stuff after weigh-ins and
I look over and she's just like Tim's
like I'm like I can throw a plate of
watermelon at her I can throw a table